- I'm at a supermarket in Hong Kong
and the shelves are empty.
At some stores they've started limiting
how much you can buy,
staples like canned food or toilet paper.
- [Narrator] Panic buying is just one way
people in Hong Kong have reacted
as the government has put
in draconian restrictions
to control the fast
spreading Omicron variant.
For about two years,
the city largely shut out COVID 19
but it has been fighting
a record surge in cases
that's overwhelmed hospitals.
A low vaccination rate among the elderly
has also driven its death rate
to the highest in the world.
So here's how everyday life
in Hong Kong has changed
and why many are rushing
to leave Asia's global hub?
Here in the city, daily
life has become complicated,
forcing many to reevaluate
Hong Kong as home.
Vaccine passports are now required
to get around the city
and the unvaccinated can't
shop in supermarkets and malls.
Summer break for students
started earlier in March
instead of July because the
government closed schools
so they could be converted
into testing and isolation centers.
Gyms are shut too,
and people can't eat out after 6:00 PM,
which has hurt a lot of businesses.
- This is Hong Kong
central business district.
Around lunchtime
restaurants used to be busy
with bankers and lawyers,
but these days it's pretty quiet
and a lot of restaurants
and stores have had to shut.
- [Narrator] Government
resources have also been pulled
to battle the outbreak.
Authorities have been quickly
building temporary hospitals
and massive isolation sites.
There's also a dedicated taxi fleet
to ferry the sick to clinics.
But some government proposals
which have been integral
to China's ability to
quickly tame COVID spikes
have sparked panic among residents.
In late February, local health authority
said the government couldn't rule out
whether to impose a citywide lockdown
to test an entire population.
Fearing the worst,
residents scramble to
stock upon everything
from toiletries to food,
leaving many store shelves empty.
A few days later this
city's chief executive
said there were no plans
for a wholesale lockdown.
Instead she said the government's priority
would be reducing the number
of deaths and severe illnesses.
But the government's
messaging hasn't been enough
to convince many residents to stay.
- This is Central Station.
It used to be one of Hong
Kong's busiest metro stops.
A few months ago, it was bustling.
And this emptiness now is just one sign
of the sheer number of
people this city is losing.
- [Narrator] According
to immigration data,
nearly 69,000 more Hong Kong
residents have left the city
and arrived this year,
with almost 80% of those
leaving in February
as the city's pandemic
controls kicked into full gear.
Hong Kong officials have called for calm
and reassured residents
there would be enough supplies
of food and essentials.
But as pressure from
business groups has mounted,
authorities in late March said the city
would scrap flight ban from some countries
and cut quarantine for returning residents
from 14 days to seven.
The government also said it would relax
some social distancing rules from April.
But China is also facing
its biggest outbreak
since the start of the pandemic
and authorities they
have kicked into action
by ordering millions to stay
home and restricting travel.
However, Chinese president
Xi Jinping has vowed
to reduce the impacts of
those measures on the economy
and on people's lives.
Health authorities have
also said that patients
with no symptoms or mild ones
should go to isolation facilities,
freeing up space in hospitals.
It's a small step in easing restrictions,
but as long as Hong Kong remains aligned
with China's policies,
life in the city won't return to normal
until the number of
cases are under control.